now that black panther is out the next
Marvel movie we have to look forward to
is the one we've all been waiting for
Avengers infinity war if you caught the
first video I did everything you need to
know about the Infinity stones you know
that Avengers infinity war it will be
all about Thanos trying to collect the
Infinity stones for his Infinity
Gauntlet and the Avengers trying to stop
him
Thanos is one of the most if not the
most powerful villains in Marvel history
so it's gonna be an awesome movie and I
can't wait till it comes out in May with
it coming out so soon I want to do some
recaps and theories on where some of our
favorite characters are at in the MCU
and what I expect to see in infinity war
I want to start this series off with one
of my all-time favorite heroes and
Avenger the Mighty Thor if you haven't
seen Thor Ragnarok yet go see it
seriously it's the best Thor movie so
far and it's both hilarious and
action-packed
also here's your official spoiler alert
if you haven't seen the movie yet the
main thing I want to talk about in this
video is Thor's hammer Mjolnir and thor
ragnarok hella the goddess of death
breaks me on there and might I add with
ease and our Mighty Thor goes the entire
movie without his hammer the store get
me on their back at the end of the movie
nope for those of you who haven't seen
it he goes the entire movie without
meow-meow but with a little help from
his father Odin he finds the power
within himself and becomes even stronger
now does this mean that Thor's without
his hammer from now on not likely in an
Instagram post by the Russo brothers we
see the hammer on set and more
importantly we specifically see the
original mule near I'll touch more on
this in a bit so some of you might be
asking this Thor lose his hammer in the
comics the answer is oh yeah many many
times this leaves the question of how
does Thor get his hammer back and also
what hammer will he have here are some
of my theories before you actually state
my theories I think it should be known
that in the comics there are two
storylines unworthy Thor and Thor
ultimate in this video I'll be talking
about both but I won't go too into
detail because I want to stick to what I
think we'll see in the upcoming infinity
war movies so let's start with the
Instagram post by the Russo brothers I
mentioned earlier what's difficult here
is to truly know if the hammer is
actually in infinity war or if the
directors
are just teasing us let's briefly act
like they're not teasing us and go a
little into how mule near could be fixed
one way in the comics is that Loki
actually fixes it for Thor this is
possible since it appears that Loki has
turned good and has a good relationship
of Thor at the end of Ragnarok but I
think we all know that this won't last
and he'll be fighting with Thanos at
some point in infinity war another way
Milner is fixed is that a celestial beam
fixes it this is very unlikely to show
up in infinity war though what I
personally believe will happen if they
take it this way is that we will see
Thor ultimate from the comics in the
ultimate series Tony Stark actually
fixes Mjolnir forth or I can see this
happening especially after the end
credits scene in Black Panther where
T'Challa says he will be sharing by
brainian with the world essentially
taking Starks brains and tech and the
most powerful metal on earth and
combining them to make mule in there
even better yep I can see ultimate tech
millionaire happening let's say Muller
doesn't come back though what are the
other options I for one think a great
weapon to see an infinity war it would
be yarn borne the battle axe Indian
worthy Thor Odin's son actually yields
this axe when he loses his hammer due to
unworthiness and it was actually Thor's
primary weapon before he became worthy
of Mjolnir in the first place and after
Ragnarok the current Thor we have is the
unworthy Thor yawen was forged by the
same dwarves that forged Mjolnir and is
blessed with Thor's on blood and again
it's the primary weapon that Thor wields
in the comic series the unworthy Thor
also not to mention that the unworthy
Thor has short hair much like our MCU
Thor has now so I can see it making an
appearance in infinity war at least for
a brief moment but I actually would
absolutely love to see is for ultimate
mule NER to make an appearance as you
can see ultimate mule in there is both a
hammer and a battle axe in the comics
there's a comet-like dimensional rift
that smashes into old Asgard and then a
missional rift is ultimate meal there
there's also a different storyline where
ultimate Mjolnir is tech based and human
made this could come in to infinity war
in a couple different ways just as I
mentioned the original mule NER could
come back the ultimate mule NER could
come to us by Tony Stark using his tech
and vibranium from Wakanda forged
together another theory is that Thor
actually took the hammer and thor
ragnarok
knowing that he would have
leave Asgard this of course is assuming
that the hammer already landed on Asgard
the hammer doesn't actually have a
worthiness enchantment on it so Thor
could have easily given it to someone to
take and look after the reason I think
there's a good possibility of this
hammer showing up is because of new
official concept art that Marvel
released as you can see it doesn't show
the actual hammer head it just shows the
handle but if you look closely at the
handle it's much longer than the
original me linear and it also looks a
lot like ultimate Mjolnir what I'm
guessing is that Thor was somehow
forging new hammer by going to the doors
of Nadav lair who forged the original
mule near I'd imagine it will have some
vibranium in it as well and that Stark
will have some involvement at the same
time this will actually tie a few of the
different comic series together which is
sort of what Marvel has been doing in
the movies these are just a few of my
theories on what we could possibly see
an Avengers Infinity Ward coming out in
May of this year what are some of your
theories I'd love to hear from everyone
just drop a comment below and let me
know what you think we'll see an
infinity war hopefully you enjoyed this
video and give it a thumbs up and be
sure to subscribe to my channel to stay
up to date with all things infinity war
Marvel and superhero thank you so much
for watching and have a great day